that's actually my morning must listen
the president taking a jab at the
rollout of the Affordable Care Act take
a listen of course we rolled out
healthcare.gov that could have gone
better in 2008 my slogan was yes we can
in 2013 my slogan was control-alt-delete
the president always had pretty good
timing with his drugs what what got the
biggest chuckle orange is the new black
by far orange is the new black when he
talked about how he really likes john
boehner i think we have a shot let's
listen these days the House Republicans
actually give John Boehner a harder time
than they give me which means orange
really is the new black I mean scar I
don't know who wrote that joke we can't
say that the President did he took the
doors off people loved it he had two
ferns on either side of him Joel McHale
was incredible but also its White House
Correspondents weekend though Erik
schatzker just asked me why'd you have a
good time I don't know super famous
celebrities politicians beautiful
parties of black tie I kind of like a
finition of really fun but so I mean
that's how shots key roles were two diff
one thing that that works really well in
the president's favor is that he's a bit
of a pop culture junkie right i mean he
likes watching all these TV shows like
orange is the new black Game of Thrones
he got the advance copy of it or
everything I mean he's he's really up to
date on his pop culture and his TV
watching yeah I mean I they but all in
all it was a big success rate huge net
or toward in your success Bloomberg
Vanity Fair after party off the charts
yes girl i came home with six in the
morning i'm not sure how sona's gonna
work out it i would say well but that's
alright because that way you were able
to go home and get a quick shower before
you had to go to church right sunday
totally obviously I talked to El hun
about this on Friday how this whole
shindig has morphed over 15 down 20
years yeah what's his take on the
difference now verses 12 doesn't go out
of the go it's hot it with it usually I
have not robbed kendrick jersey girl AI
mean chris Christie also took a lot of
hits in during they did chris Christie
was front and center he was getting
abused but he was there having a good
time brought his wife dancing snacking